[Music]
hey there I'm back today with another
reaction video which is where I respond
to videos that you the viewer send our
way if there's a video you want to see
me react to like this let me know in the
comments down below today we're going to
be listening to a clip from Dr Michael
Brown's radio program the line of fire
this should be interesting an Adventist
called into his live show uh a number of
years ago to talk with Dr Brown about of
course the Sabbath now this should be
interesting considering Dr Brown is a
Jewish convert to Christianity who does
not affirm the seventh day Sabbath as
being binding on Christians it appears
to be Audio Only so let's listen in
we'll go to De Mo Iowa Frank welcome to
the line of
fire caller your last caller was exactly
wrong as a 58-year old 7thday Adventist
grew up in the faith seventh day
Adventists do not believe in any way
shape or form they're the only ones that
going to be saved as opposed to the
Jehovah WI wies and the 144,000 we do
not take that position there will be all
all people Sunday Keepers in church
Etc ah so a 58-year-old 7th Adventist
and he claims that the SDA Church in no
way shape or form teaches that they're
the only ones that will be saved yeah
I've talked about this I don't even know
how many times at this point on the
channel explaining why this isn't
entirely forthright but let's crack this
can of worms once again first first
let's look at an article from the SDA
Church's own website regarding their
fundamental belief number 13 The Remnant
and its Mission then we will look at the
fundamental beliefs book in conjunction
with this they write quote the Apostle
John the last of Jesus's disciples and
the one who wrote Revelation tells us
exactly who Satan will Target Satan's
goal is to harm those who keep God's
Commandments and believe what Jesus
taught but among the lawlessness of the
corrupted World God will call for his
devoted followers to separate themselves
from those who have rejected him then
they cite Revelation then I heard
another voice from Heaven saying come
out of Babylon my people lest you take
part in her sins lest you share in her
plagues for her sins are heaped high as
heaven and God has remembered her
iniquities those who do not come out of
the wickedness of the world will be
subject to the same fate as Satan utter
destruction God refuses to let sin go on
forever and those who hold on to sin
will have to account for their deeds but
God's Remnant people are not just
supposed to hide in holes as they
separate themselves from The World God
has a job for his people to do a message
they will deliver for many people this
message will make the difference between
eternal life with God and the permanent
second death all who hear it will have
to make a single vital decision either
to follow God or side with Satan and
share his fate close quote so the
Seventh Adventist church is allegedly
foreseen in the Book of Revelation as
God's last day Remnant who keep the Ten
Commandments and have the faith of Jesus
by which they mean they have the
apostolic faith restored that's what
adventism is supposed to be in the last
days which allegedly began in 1798 God
is supposedly using adventism to call
Christians who are true devoted
followers out from where they are to
join them or they will share in the same
fate as Satan notice it said God will
call his devoted followers to sep
separate themselves from those who have
rejected God meaning Christians are a
part of the Lawless world that have
actually rejected God if you reject
their message after hearing it it is
seen as you want to hold on to your sin
we're supposedly Babylon if you're not
an Adventist you're not a devoted
follower of God and the unique job that
God supposedly has for Adventists is to
call Christians out from where they are
to join them as the remnant those that
hear the SDA Church's novel controversy
Theology and reject it they will be
damned because it's their unique message
of Salvation that will supposedly have a
person ready for the second
coming now notice what the fundamental
beliefs book says in conjunction with
this quote God has his children in all
churches but through the remnant church
he proclaims a message that is to
restore his true worship by calling his
people out of the apostasy and preparing
them for Christ's return recognizing
that many of God's people have yet to
join them the remnant sense their
inadequacies and weakness when they try
to fulfill this solemn Mission they
realize that it is only through God's
grace that they can accomplish their
momentous task close quote so it's only
an ignorance that those outside of
adventism are saved God's people in
other churches are only gods in so much
as they have yet to leave where they are
the only Christians outside of adventism
that are right with God are those who
will eventually hear the SDA message and
come join them or those who die in
ignorance before hearing it but the
caller doesn't say it like this he tries
to make it sound like they're just like
the rest of us when no they are
targeting Christians and claiming that
we are apostate especially those of us
who have seen the Folly of administ
Theology and
left again in the same chapter Under The
Heading of the mission of the remnant
they write quote the Prophecies of the
Book of Revelation clearly outline the
mission of the remnant The Three Angels
messages of Revelation for 6-12 reveal
the proclamation of the remnant that
will bring a full and final restoration
of the Gospel truth close quote so
Christian this movement has a different
gospel and Mission than the Christian
church just like the other
restorationist groups who all claimed
that the gospel completely fell away and
God raised them up to restore it the SDA
church is an ecclesial body they think
that they are the one true people of God
plus that they have Apostolic
Christianity restored and our worship as
a Christian is an Abomination before God
that he doesn't even accept which is
also said in the same chapter of the
fundamental belief's book which we will
look at in a moment but I want to remind
people this is also not entirely correct
because what they call the Three Angels
messages are not Apostolic in origin
whatsoever they're even on record
admitting this which means it can't be
Apostolic Christianity restored this is
just one of the many examples from the
SDA Church's own church paper review and
Herald quote the very fact that this
Prophecy of the Three Angels messages
covers the period between 1844 and the
end of this age shows conclusively that
this threefold message is God's special
message for us at this very hour just as
surely as we are living between 1844 and
the coming of Christ just so surely may
we know that this three-fold message of
Revelation 14 6-12 is God's present
Truth for this present time the time for
this message is very definitively fixed
to the present generation this prophecy
of Revelation 14 6-14 does not and
cannot refer to any proclamation of the
Gospel in the days of the Apostles the
early Christian fathers or the reformers
of the 16th 17th or 18th centuries it is
strictly a Last Day message applicable
to those who live just before the return
of Christ close quote so what the SDA
Church teaches about how you can be made
right with God wasn't what the apostles
preached it is a different gospel
message that only they have and it's
this message that they're taking to
Christians to try and lead them after
this false gospel that's not Apostolic
in origin the apostles didn't preach for
example you need to understand and
believe the seven-step sanctuary model
including the investigative judgment in
order to receive the Forgiveness of sins
that the mark of the beast is going to
be going to church on Sunday and you
must believe and accept this for the
Forgiveness of your sins but back to
this claim that adventism teaches there
are Christians outside of their movement
back to the beliefs book they write
quote every person will have to choose
whom to worship either one's choice of
righteousness by faith will be revealed
as one participates in a form of worship
God has endorsed or one's effectual
participation in a form of righteousness
by works will be revealed as one
participates in a form of worship that
God has forbidden but that the Beast and
His image command a human-made worship
God cannot accept this latter form of
worship because it gives priorities to
the Commandments of human beings and not
to those of God it seeks justification
through human works and not by faith
that comes through a total surrender to
God as Creator Redeemer and recreator in
this sense then the message of the third
Angel is the message of justification by
faith close quote so God rejects the
worship of the Christian church he can't
accept it because it is allegedly based
upon man made Commandments that God has
forbidden God is actually forbidden
worshiping him on the first day anyone
that does so isn't trusting in Christ
for salvation but they're relying upon
their Works supposedly and this is
supposed to be what justification by
faith is talking about submitting to
what the Adventist Church tells you
Revelation is saying and then believing
their narcissistic reading of the
biblical text the caller is trying to
make it sound like adventism is just
another Protestant group trying to
downplay the very bold claims that the
organization makes about Christians not
giving the full picture and the full
scope many of these claims by the way
would be classified as bearing false
witness but point being Christians do
not be fooled by this posturing that
adventism is on our team the
organizational beliefs are an enemy of
the Gospel of Jesus Christ and the
Christian Church they think we are
apostate and rejected by God our only
functional use for them is to try and
make Adventist converts that's why they
want to build inroads with Christians to
start trying to evangelize us not
because they see themselves as being on
the same team with the same mission that
was Ellen White's Council to the
organization and it's why they have
beliefs that are called entering wedge
doctrines but I I I think you need to
understand if if you want to argue that
God didn't dictate the people to follow
the Sabbath at creation we can at least
acknowledge he rested on the seventh day
then at Mount Si he says remember this
7th day even though Mana was collected
um you know the collection of Mana was
dictated before Sinai but he used the
word remember remember cannot possibly
pre-exist the event just as as your wife
would put a reminder note for a dental
appointment on your refrigerator she's
not going to remind you of an event that
hasn't already happened and Isaiah 6622
and 23 says the sabath okay can I just
ask one thing doesn't God often say
remember when he institutes something in
other words remember this from this day
on remember this the other time it uses
it uses two words in Hebrew Z and and
shamor zor is remember shamur is keep
and there are many things God institutes
and says right remember this don't I'm
telling you this remember it so it can
be you can be told to remember it from
the day it's
instituted I guess it would come down to
this if you want to know the truth from
a Seventh Day Adventist I'll give you
the unb barnish truth it I guess it
depends on your view of the Book of
Revelation if you believe it's a prous
view uh historic view an idealist view
um you know you your particular belief
on a futurist view what you believe on
that but I would suggest you so like I
mentioned earlier Dr Brown is not a
savarian but this was interesting
because they're at the end he appeal to
eschatology and said that depending on
what school of thought you belong to
that's going to influence how you
understand the word remember in the
fourth Commandment I'm not sure how that
logically follows but okay now folks
personally I've never liked this
argument I'll remind folks who might be
new I am a sabari but not a 7eventh day
sabbatarian and 95% of the Adventist
Church's Arguments for things like the
perpetuity of the Sabbath and the
Sabbath predating Sinai and so on all of
those are taken from Christian
sabbatarians that came before them they
just try and claim that we were wrong
about the day everything else that we
say and and and claim about the Sabbath
home run we're going to use all your
arguments you're just wrong about the
day apparently but there are stronger
arguments out there than the remember
one that this guy presented because what
Dr Brown pointed out is exactly correct
the word remember doesn't have to denote
the past experience or existence of
something it could come with the
introduction of something new as a
starting imperative from that point
moving forward the New Testament namely
Hebrews 4 really is the key on
understanding the Sabbath in light of
Jesus accomplishing Redemption but the
caller mentioned God resting on the
seventh day so let's see if he ever
mentions both Sabbath acts of God
because the word Sabbath means cease
rest Etc where God entered his rest two
different days after accomplishing two
different creative works because
understanding that is key to
holistically understanding the Sabbath
I've talked about this I don't know how
many times the New Creation in the new
creation God entered his rest a new day
not the seventh day the first day that
that if the if the Sabbath is going to
be kept in the heaven and in in the new
Earth wouldn't it stand a reason that
God's going to reinstitute his Sabbath
and his law on men's Hearts just stay
stay right there stay right there
because we got a break uh yeah but it's
also that the feasts are going to be
kept so how come sth day Adventists
don't keep the rest of the biblical
calendar so I'll come back to you Frank
I'll de side of the break exactly what
Michael Brown said at the end there
Adventists will use Isaiah 66 to say
that proves the seventh day Sabbath will
be kept in heaven which is then used to
say so therefore it's still binding
presently except as Dr Brown pointed out
it also says from New Moon to New Moon
which would mean Adventists should be
observing the new moons if they wanted
to be consistent in their argumentation
Revelation is clear that at the
consummation of all things and the
fullness of the new heavens and new
earth being ushered in there will be no
sun and moon there's not going to be
days like there currently is Isaiah 66
is for telling of the new creation it
anticipates the time when all things
will be made new as a result of Christ's
incarnation according to Isaiah 66 7-9
this includes a new heavens and new
earth but prior to that time there will
be changes in God's people there will be
changes in the extent of the typological
blessings of Deuteronomy 28 according to
Isaiah 65: 20-2 and even changes in
worship Isaiah 66 1-4 and church
government the phrasing of from New Moon
to New Moon and Sabbath the Sabbath are
simply an all-encompassing way for
Isaiah who is in the middle of
explaining the expansion of God's people
to all tribes tongues peoples and
Nations chapters uh
64-66 they are all a chain that's for
telling of Jesus who would come and make
all things new well that's precisely
what the red letters of Revelation 215
say that Jesus is presently doing from
the throne as he rules and Reigns point
being understanding the doctrine of the
new creation is key and Isaiah 66 is not
proof that the seventh day Sabbath is
going to be kept in eternity the Sabbath
day functions as a type that points to
the greater reality the Eternal rest of
God that we as Believers have yet to
physically enter into but once we arrive
in that antitypical state the type is no
longer
necessary a a very good point that Frank
from De Mo Iowa just raised about
Sabbath observance uh even if we put
aside The Book of Revelation uh we can
see in some of the prophetic books the
end of the book of Isaiah that in the
millennial Kingdom so when the Lord
comes establishes his kingdom on the
earth which many of us are expecting
Thousand-Year Reign on the earth or some
would say the world to come it speaks of
the Sabbath being observed so if it's
going to be observed by the whole world
uh in the next age why not now the the
the problem is if you want to argue that
and I have Messianic Jewish friends that
argue that it also talks about new moons
and it also talks about the feasts for
example Zechariah 14 after Jesus returns
the whole world comes to Jerusalem to
celebrate the Feast of Tabernacles so my
question for many years to sth Day
Adventist would be why not the rest of
the biblical calendar so Frank with that
same logic and and I think it's a great
point I agree with you it's it's an
important Point why uh what about SE uh
Passover 1 Corinthians 5 Paul says let's
observe the Passover says it to to the
Corinthians there uh and then we have
Feast of Tabernacles clearly kept in in
the millennial Kingdom Zechariah 14 so
why aren't you as a Seventh Day
Adventist keeping the entire biblical
calendar that God gave to
Israel well first I would suggest to you
I mean I don't I don't intend to dodge
your question I guess but I would
suggest to you that that people all
through history who were given who who
kept the light
given will be in the Kingdom I mean
clearly there will be those who kept
Sunday as the truth and the knowledge
given them and they will be included in
the Kingdom I have no problem no issue
with that so that's where I totally
disagree with Tom the color we do not
believe us 7 Adventist to be some Elite
group that is only going to heaven but
where where this comes down to the Brass
tax is the the the the the futurist view
or the Predator view of Revelation some
people believe this Mark some people
believe this beast power in Revelation
is Nero it can't be Nero the eight clues
in Revelation 13 does not point to Nero
it points to one thing and I would
suggest that the Mark or the Seal of
let's start with the Seal of the Living
God the the only thing that is going to
protect you from The Mark of the Beast
that is going to be foed upon all men
Great and Small is the Seal of the
Living God we would cont we would con we
would contend that the seal is in the
fourth Commandment being that any in any
good presidential seal is name title and
territory ruled which would be you know
such as President Obama you know
president United States Etc so the Seal
of the Living God would be uh God name
Creator make
would be his his title his territory
ruled would be heavens and earth yeah he
didn't intend to dodge but Dodge he did
Dr Brown asked why if he wants to be
consistent in his argumentation does he
not see the feast days and New Moon
festivals to also be eternally
perpetually binding because they're
mentioned
also how does his response of bringing
up the mark of the beast as the
presidential seal analogy how does that
deal with this oh brother Christian when
you hear this argument understand
Adventists have simply inherited this
from the SDA Pioneers such as uh Roswell
F cotal who wrote quote a law in order
to have any Force to impel obedience
must have a seal which is a sign of the
authority of lawgiver indicating the
extent of his domain and consequently
his right to rule for example the
president of the United States issues an
order to the Army and simply signs it
with his name Abraham Lincoln no officer
in command under him would dare to obey
the order why not because the document
is wanting in an important particular it
does not tell us which of the Abraham
Lincoln is its author the title and the
seal are wanting but let him add to his
name president of the United States and
a fix the Seal of the government and the
order will be obeyed this addition is
the mark of his name or authority it
tells who Abraham Lincoln is he is
President it gives us the extent of his
jurisdiction the United States and being
the rightful ruler he must be obeyed
close quote except obviously scripture
nowhere says this analogy is an example
for the Ten Commandments but SDA
theology has to do all sorts of circus
tricks and mental gymnastics to try and
avoid the obvious which is that
Ephesians 13 explicitly verbatim states
that the holy spirit is the Seal of God
if you're a Christian expect an
Adventist to tell you that the Holy
Spirit does the ceiling but isn't the
seal itself well this is a false
dichotomy because it's a both and not an
either or Ephesians 1113 is plain
biblical milk I've heard Adventists
trying to argue there's two seals the
Holy Spirit and the Seal of the law
being sealed with the Holy Spirit isn't
enough being born again in and of itself
is not
enough you have to also have the Seal of
the law that's what really matters The
Telltale sign that someone has gone
unfortunately completely off the rails
and will go to any extreme to defend
their tradition because that's exactly
what this is it is a tradition it is not
biblical it is their tradition it's what
they want to believe it's what they
believe to be true and it's what their
Pioneers concocted with the supposed
Divine stamp of approval from God
through Ellen White but it is a
tradition I'm still thinking about how
he juked over to this subject away from
whether or not the new moons and feast
days according to his own standard would
also have to be eternally perpetually
binding based on his own
argumentation so we believe it's going
to come down to two systems Babylonian
system Israel system and and and it's
going to be a false bride and a pure
bride one is going to keep the the false
day that the papacy poed on us all right
so so hang on so in the end those who
don't keep the seventh day Sabbath will
not make it in they'll be part of the
false church but there will be a call to
the World by Elijah who would but H hang
hang on hang on hang on you are saying
that in the end just is real simple in
the end those who do not observe the
seventh day Sabbath will not be part of
the true church well let me ask you this
question with a question when God drew a
line in Israel and those who got you
give me a yes or could you give me your
yes or no on this one Dr Brown is on the
unfortunate SDA Margo round never really
getting straight answers never getting
to the bottom of a point before chasing
a new Squirrel Round and Round it goes
but the caller said it's going to come
down to two systems Babylon system and
God's system folks this is narca Jesus
of adventism in full force here for
those that do not know Nara Jesus I
believe uh was a term that's coined by
Lutheran Pastor Chris Roseboro from
fighting for the faith but it's when
someone reads themselves into all of the
Bible That's precisely what adventism is
it's one big case of narca Jesus
Revelation had application to people
long before adventism even existed
the Babylonian system and the remnant
have been around long before the SDA
movement folks I've talked about this
elsewhere including on our website so
you can go check all that out there but
the remnant is literally all of those
who were called out of the world and
raised to spiritual newness of Life made
a living Stone in the body of Christ
Jesus being the Chief Cornerstone of
that structure Babylon is simply the
kingdom of darkness which every human
being by default is Born Into to try and
make it about adventism versus the rest
of the world is a juvenile and
self-centered reading of the Bible that
totally detaches it from history you
can't just read the Bible in the 19th
century and then just start plugging in
all these modern things just craziness
but folks I want you to notice the focus
of the SDA
collar in the crosshairs of the SDA
scope is
Christians we're seen as no different
than the Wicked World to
them the caller initially started by
claiming that they don't believe they're
the only ones that'll be saved and I
showed you what this means in the in a
fuller light he then went on to even
admit as much by saying well they'll
only be accountable to the light that
they were given meaning those outside of
their fold can only be saved in
ignorance but not those of us who have
heard their bad arguments and false
gospel and rejected it we are damned and
God has rejected us and our worship
can't be accepted by him now I recently
did a stream on the historical
grammatical method of bble
interpretation which SDA leadership
claims to uphold for those that saw that
stream folks what did I tell you a more
accurate description of their
interpretation method would
be what Donald casbolt called an
allegorical typological historical
interpretation method that's what we
what we heard here it wasn't just narcog
Jesus but allegory to read themselves
into the text the caller tried saying
Elijah in Revelation 11 is a picture of
the Adventist
Church God's people and they'll be
heralding this warning call the loud Cry
Of The Three Angels messages to get out
of Babylon and come join them before
it's too late yet that isn't at all what
the original audience of Revelation
would have understood Elisha to be
representative of just another example
there that the SDA church does not
affirm the hgm and the way they treat
the Bible trickles down to the leoty who
then make these claims like this point
being do not fall for for the baate that
avenus theology teaches like they're
they're just like the rest of us they're
just another Protestant denomination now
I'm going to keep saying this no
Baptists aren't targeting lutherans and
anglicans
Etc we have fun in-house discussions and
banter and
disagreements but we don't claim that if
you don't come join our denomination the
wrath of God's going to be poured out on
you Etc I did Street evangelism for
years prior to answering adventism I was
out there with a Lutheran a Pentecostal
guy two Baptists and a
non-denominational
guy we had the same mission same
message our doctrinal differences were
on secondary matters we're not out there
discussing with people our differences
around like church
governance understanding of the local
church government governance model you
know that's the difference between one
of the main differences between
Presbyterians and
Baptists no we're out there talking
about the gospel that has nothing to do
with the
gospel not all of theology in the Bible
just because something's in the Bible
doesn't make it the gospel we were out
there same Mission taking the same God
and the same gospel message to the lost
world adventism does not share that with
us they have their own special message
and their own special mission that God
exclusively gave to them and no one else
but Dr Brown was starting to press him
on needing to be an SDA to be saved so
let's keep
listening you said chance to the last
day world to come out of Sunday worship
and Jo okay so those who are those who
are part of Sunday worship are part of
the false Church those who are part of
Sunday worship are part of the false
Church The Babylon system correct they
refuse to come out when they're given
simple yes or no Frank if you believe
this to say yes if that's a year okay so
yeah just to be clear seventh day
Adventists seventh day Adventists
believe that if you worship Sunday and
you set aside Sunday as the Sabbath that
is part of the false church and the B on
system we believe a national day of
worship will be set up and instituted in
this country much like Shadrach mhach
and abzo how about right right now right
now if people say that Sabbath is Sunday
and they set that day aside is that part
of the Babylon false system no if if
they are keeping it today and it's the
truth and the light given them and they
die tomorrow I fully expect to see those
people in the Kingdom I'm talking but
the day will come in the future the day
will come in the future you believe
oh brother this guy said Christians
refuse to come out when they've been
given a warning this is just one giant
begging of the question no we refuse to
leave where we are because adventism has
a false gospel a false god is a false
Church all bound together by a false
prophet it was born out of severe
theological confusion and pride its
theology could rightly be called swiss
cheese theology because of how many
holes it has it's a system that affirms
numerous ancient ient heresies that even
someone with a sophomoric level
understanding of church history could
point out why would I leave my thriving
local church where word and Sacrament
Ministry is taking place every week to
join a sectarian doomsday movement that
just constantly beats people over the
head with the law doesn't understand the
Law's proper use is leading people after
a different
God why would I leave my local thriving
Church to join this sectarian doomsday
movement that's proven time and time
again they shouldn't be trusted to tell
us anything about the
Bible where they have their own novel
worldview that's entirely foreign to the
Bible and it's a bizarre hybrid of
Mormon pre-earth fiction and John
Milton's Paradise
Lost there's not one single reason what
one single good reason to leave where I
am and come join them in fact there's a
mountain of reasons not to do so but on
a something that I've pointed out
numerous times before the caller did the
appeal to ignorance thing again to get
Dr Brown off his case he said it will
only be in the future that setting aside
Sunday will be problematic yeah this is
not true because notice what Ellen White
claimed and she has more Authority than
this guy this is the final year of her
life folks quote I am instructed to say
gather from the scriptures the proofs
that God has Sanctified the seventh day
and let these proofs be read before the
congregation
let those who have not heard the truth
be shown that all who turn aside from a
plain thus sayeth the Lord must suffer
the result of their course in all ages
the Sabbath has been the test of loyalty
to God it is a sign between me and the
children of Israel forever the Lord
declares close quote so God allegedly
told Ellen White that Adventists are to
gather from the scriptures all their
proofs that God Sanctified the seventh
day and let them be read before the
congregations so that those who haven't
heard these truths can hear them and
come join the SDA Church those that
don't you're going to suffer the
consequences because the Sabbath has
allegedly been a test in
what all generations folks even if the
seventh day Sabbath were proven to be
binding on Christians that doesn't
vindicate adventism the seventh day
Sabbath is not unique to them so no it
isn't only a futuristic problem to
worship on Sunday when the Phantom
Sunday law comes that's when they claim
worshiping on Sunday they will become
the mark of the beast but if you hear
their butchering of scripture and outof
context proof text today and you
disagree you are now condemned and
you're not loyal to God because you
didn't come and join them exactly like I
showed earlier from their website and
the fundamental beliefs book they
claimed that God is unable to accept our
worship remember that God has closed for
worship on Sunday why are we why are we
called the Seventh Day Adventist because
we believe in the seventh day and we
believe in that Advent or the second
coming so at Christ's Second Coming God
will reinstitute his law that was given
at creation reminded of its sin and
going to be kept in the heaven and the
new Earth forever and before he enters
in and and and stops the great
controversy between between Satan and
God that started in heaven the Rebellion
that was started in heaven he will
reinstitute his true Sabbath all right
all right hang on that's got nothing to
do with my question Mercy this guy is
all over the place unfortunately this is
how a lot of conversations with
Adventists go lots of assertions of the
SDA script but very hard to get them to
just directly and clearly answer
anything it's always these long
dissertations and I get it sometimes an
answer to something is is a lot more
than yes or no or there's Nuance Etc and
I get all that but dude he's just
clearly dodging here Dr Brown was
pressing him on whether or not keeping
the seventh day Sabbath is required for
salvation now he's transition into
talking about the great controversy and
the alleged claim that this started in
heaven before the Earth was created and
when Jesus returns to end the
controversy started by Satan he's going
to reinstitute the true Sabbath which
will be kept in the new heavens and the
new Earth overthrowing the papal Sabbath
of Sunday yada yada we already looked at
how they butcher Isaiah 66 to try and
prove this but folks the Bible nowhere
says that Satan's rebellion in heaven
was over the Ten
Commandments that he began attacking the
Ten Commandments the character of God
adventus I'm sorry but no amount of
mental gymnastics and Bible twisting
will make this so this is coming from
outside the text and it's asserted to
not contradict the Bible so therefore
it's valid to say that it's biblical
this is what the caller is referring to
and is allegedly plainly in the Bible
Adventist will constantly tell us you
don't even need Ellen White everything
we believe is just in the Bible I can
prove it all from the Bible okay quote
Satan grew bold in his rebellion and
expressed his contempt of the Creator's
law this Satan could not bear he claimed
that Angels needed no law but should be
left free to follow their own will which
would ever guide them right that law was
a restriction of their Liberty and that
to abolish law was one great object of
his standing as he did the condition of
the Angels he thought needed Improvement
not so the mind of God who had made laws
and exalted them equal to himself the
happiness of the Angelic host consisted
in their perfect obedience to law close
quote where is this in the Bible book
chapter and verse that Satan told the
angels that they needed no law as his
contempt for the Ten Commandments grew
such that he couldn't bear it anymore
book chapter and verse for where the
Angels were keeping the Ten Commandments
in this unknown expanse of time prior to
the creation of the earth and I say that
because notice this covenant theology
chart I've shown this before this was
made by an Adventist Pastor who I was
listening to try and teach avenus
covenant theology for those that do not
know covenant theology is really just a
nickname for reformed theology well this
movement stole that framework and
filtered it through the great
controversy theme resulting in this
chaotic mess of their own flavor of
covenant theology but notice before
human creation you have Angelic creation
and the Angelic fall which are unknown
periods of
time well it would have had to have been
a long enough period for all this
pre-earth origin narrative to happen for
Lucifer to be able to grow in his rage
deceive a 30 angels Etc so since they
essentially claim that Genesis 1:1
doesn't include the Angels but only the
Earth I'm not sure where in scripture
that one can appeal to to tell us all
about this primordial imagining we need
book chapter and verse that Satan told
the angels that the Ten Commandments
were a restriction to their Liberty and
that their condition needed
Improvement you know because angels can
totally commit adultery even though
they're not given in
marriage they can obey their parents
plural
it's all these added details that make
up this story line and then the story
line is brought to the Bible to try and
support the GU in conclusion that when
Jesus returns at the second coming it
will be to restore the true Sabbath and
end the controversy that Satan started
over the Ten Commandments yet none of
this storyline is
biblical my question is you said that
there will be an antichrist system and
and they will set up so those who say
after the based on your interpretation
after the Antichrist sets up his system
and has uh a day other than Saturday as
the day of worship and rest those who
are not setting apart the seventh day
Sabbath they will be under the
Antichrist under Babylon under a false
system correct absolutely 100% all right
so clear clear enough hey we we are we
are out of time Frank I just wanted you
to make yourself clear so the day will
come
the day will come according to this
58-year 7th Day Adventist that if you
are under an antichrist who will make
this the world law that if you are not
setting apart the seventh day Sabbath
that you will then bow down to the mark
of the beast you will be part of the
Babylon system part of the false church
so what are last caller said was not
that off it was not that
off in other words the idea that the
true Remnant is the Seventh Day
Adventist and that those who are outside
of it are not the true church Frank and
our first caller would say no no no
that's not the case now because there's
limited light there's limited Revelation
and insight so some people just don't
have all the information okay well it's
Truth for everybody we don't have all
the information that's why we have
different groups with different
perspectives but in the end in the
end all
right those who are not
keeping the seventh day Sabbath will not
be part of the true church will be part
of the Babylon system that's why there
is great cause for concern as to where
this goes and that's why the more
radical elements of Seventh Day
Adventist I've seen their literature
I've seen it I've read it would
basically say that's the case now that
that you're ready ready in a spiritual
way to the mark of the beast uh because
you're not keeping the seventh day
Sabbath all right at least we're getting
issues on the table and my question
never got answered never got answered
the biblical calendar that spoken of in
the millennial kingdom is the whole
calendar of Israel including new moons
and including the uh feast days so why a
Sabbath singled out not the rest I think
that remains a problem Messianic hes in
that respect are much more consistent by
observing all the calendar not for
salvation but as part of Salvation
history based on some of Brown's
comments I think it was clear that he
wanted to make sure that his audience
knew that what they just heard was from
a lifelong died in the wool
Adventist since what they just heard was
bizarre I'm sure a lot of Adventists
when this first aired years ago thought
that it was great that Dr Brown blasted
this out to his large radio audience
thinking it somehow helped spread what
they call the third Angel's message when
in reality Christians hear this and
think adventism sounds absolutely nuts
I'm sorry it's just the
facts I I know that there's going to be
Adventists that wear that as a badge of
honor and think oh see they're going to
persecute us just just proves they're
going to persecute us and call us crazy
and no by nuts I mean illogical it's
illogical and you shouldn't wear uh
being illogical as a badge of honor
that checks out if if you wear that as a
badge of honor it checks out cuz this
man sounded very unstable he was all
over the place now granted if you're not
used to talking on radio or a podcast
Etc it's harder than you think and it
takes some practice so I get it but
there were so many assertions
made and not only were they simply that
assertions but they weren't even good
ones they were founded upon so many
unbiblical
assumptions but that's what avenus
theology does it is a tool of Satan to
scramble a person's mind leaving them
worse off than they were had they never
been equipped with a great controversy
worldview which is basically a mind
virus but it needs to be stated clearly
loudly and boldly Dr Brown this is not
radical adventism it's just just by the
book
adventism so I guess no it is Adventist
theology is just radical it's not some
Fringe thing is my point it is a radical
departure from Christian Orthodoxy and
many Adventists are proud of that
probably because they're the same ones
that would wear uh you know being
illogical as a badge of honor because
they have no clue what being outside of
Orthodoxy actually
means but nevertheless what Dr Brown
heard here is simply by the book
adventism lots of Adventist simply don't
like by the book adventism so they have
tried to act as you know a theological
chef and concoct their own flavor and
dish that they then insist is the
genuine
thing but what Dr Brown said at the end
there is spoton his question was never
answered we heard 10 minutes of a guy
fumble around the SDA script relying on
a number of the standard assertions he
could tell us all about Satan in heaven
you know beginning a rebellion against
the Ten Commandments and when Jesus
returns it will to Institute or
reinstitute the sth day Sabbath
overthrowing the papal Sabbath set up by
Satan that there's going to be a
national Sunday law starting in America
that eventually becomes Global and that
the Seventh Adventist movement is God's
Remnant
church but he couldn't answer a simple
yes or no that shows irrefutably the
double standard that he used when
appealing to Isaiah 66 to try and be a
support piece in all of
this it's very simple don't use the
argument that the seventh day Sabbath is
presently binding because it will be in
the new and the new Earth but then
ignore the new moons mentioned in the
same
paropy so it's simply just bad and
inconsistent argumentation comment down
below let me know your thoughts and I
will see you guys there to continue the
discussion May Christ richly bless you
in the grace and peace won by him and
his vicarious death on the cross for
Sinners until next time God
bless ho
apostate did he say
that come on man
a